here with my faithful lieutenant Sergey
and we're off to the Wagah international
border crossing this is what separates
India Pakistan most likely you've seen
it online is that very theatrical
performance both nation states put on
but what we're going to get into here in
this video is comparing and contrasting
the two performances so today we're
going to get into the Indian side of
show the Indian side and tomorrow the
Pakistani side
in 1947 after 300 years of British
occupation the British left and two
separate countries emerged India and
Pakistan it's got the feeling like we're
going to some sporting event
how much
[Music]
it's about a one kilometer walk into the
crossing first impressions
feels quite festive a lot of flags a lot
of hats a lot of shirts some food
situations and then a massive flag
through the through the haze there you
love your India meet you brother anger
then where's your hat
I thought oh but you got your you got
your hand paint little let's go oh nice
thank you are you guys ready for this
you ready we've decided
USA daddy yes Lord God - see itself yet
hey I wonder if the pack is the
Pakistani side we'll have the same
energy the same fire the friendliness
couldn't record back there a lot of
barbed wire a lot of security and
they're taking it pretty seriously
obviously
yes okay go
okay straight okay oh cool like a
standing flag over there have some
stands that are filling up here
I guess this is where the performance
happens I'm going over here this border
ceremony started in 1959 and has
happened daily ever since the border
routine India and Pakistan is 3323
kilometers long there are only five
crossing points
[Applause]
patriotic music blasts from the speakers
and organized dance takes over the
tarmac
[Music]
so I look over here to the Pakistani
side and it just really feels empty and
distant here you can see a family
crossing between the two countries a
very small percentage of Indians and
Pakistanis know what the other side is
like it's really not easy for either
nationality to get a visa to visit the
other country though the two countries
are very different the border splits the
Punjabi people apart so both sides share
linguistic culinary and cultural
similarities this video is about the BSF
the Indian border security forces the
BSF started in the Indian Pakistani war
of 1965 where the largest tank battle
happened since World War two it was a 17
day war thousands of people died on each
side the BSF now has two hundred fifty
seven thousand personnel it is known as
India's first line of defence
[Music]
[Applause]
the gates open in the rivals start with
a sportsman like handshake
[Applause]
[Music]
check out this Indian soldier she's a
master of combining gymnastic moves with
a militant March
[Applause]
[Music]
the horn star faces become more serious
[Applause]
[Music]
yes the two countries are political
enemies but there's a unity a certain
unity in the way they've choreographed
this machismo driven ballet together
[Music]
today I came from India in front of us
cool when all the way to Lahore Pakistan
which is about 45 minutes away and then
came back and now we're catching the
border from this side to see the other
perspective the security coming in here
was much tighter a lot of a lot of
checkpoints we put an official in the
back of the car the guy was driving with
new the official and he put him in the
back and then we got through all the
checkpoints super quick what do you
think it's gonna be like today what is
this gonna be like okay so here on the
Pakistani side of the approach is very
much the same patriotic music gets
louder each step as I get closer to the
border
[Music]
[Applause]
the pakistani stadium is much smaller
and almost to scale of each country's
populations India has one point three
seven billion people at Pakistan 200
million
both sides have the same chance of
zindabad even though I'm just meters
away from where I was the day before it
feels a world away the colors are
different the clothes are different the
drum beats harder thank you brother
the Rangers are Pakistan's equivalent of
India's BSF there are 25,000 Rangers in
total so these Rangers from first
impression they're much bigger and more
grizzly looking than the BSF guys the
Rangers have rock star like status and
there are better chances to interact
with them versus the Indian side both
sides have the ring leaders to fire up
the spectators different styles but
equally as effective
[Applause]
because of the smaller size of the
stadium it feels much more intimate and
connected
[Applause]
[Music]
it's Jesus uniform a huge bonus on the
Pakistani side is the live drum two
women start the parade just like the
Indian side
[Applause]
[Music]
I didn't remember seeing a sword on the
Indian side but I feel more aggression
from the Rangers
[Applause]
fine to choose between seeing an angry
BSF soldier or a ranger in dark alleyway
I definitely prefer the BSF soldier look
both could easily dismantle me in two
seconds but the Rangers size and
intensity are unmatched
[Applause]
[Music]
they're true performers with little
details like mustache twirling
[Music]
pride towards national identity feel
equally as strong on both sides of the
border
[Applause]
[Music]
whatever side I was on it connected me
more with that country so if someone
doesn't have the chance to sit on the
other side then it feels like a distant
world away
[Music]
[Applause]
even though there's that serious rivalry
and distrust between the countries
there's also that unity in the
celebration as each side needs the other
to perform
[Music]
I can tell you from my experience that
the locals are open hospitable and
friendly at both sides of this divided
and very entertaining border like and
subscribe if you want to support this
channel hit the notification Bell to be
the first to see my next video many more
videos about Pakistan and other parts of
the world coming soon